este viernes ha sido muy colombiano aquí
en tokio con las dos medallas que
consiguió colombia en bmx por una parte
gracias a carlos ramírez quien se colgó
la medalla de bronce la misma que había
conseguido en río en 2016 en una final
que no contó con el gran favorito el
campeón del mundo y el estadounidense
connor fields quien sufrió una aparatosa
caída en su tercera carrera y tuvo que
ser trasladado a un hospital y por otra
parte la reina de bmx mariana pajón
doble campeona olímpica que no logró su
tercera de título se tuvo que conformar
con la plata estuvo muy cerquita de
lograr esa hazaña 0.09 centésimas la
alejaron de la medalla de oro que
finalmente fue para la británica bbc ni
shriver y laura smolders de los países
bajos se quedó con el bronce al lado de
la felicidad colombiana pues está la
decepción francesa en ayudó con la
eliminación temprano en cuartos de final
del gigante teddy riner en la categoría
de más de 100 kilos winner quien tuvo
que conformarse con una de las dos
medallas de bronce y por otra parte esta
bajón magnético en la categoría de más
de los 78 kilos en mujeres
o mandicó que fue eliminada en
semifinales por la cubana idalys ortiz
ortiz que pasó a la final pero se quedó
con la medalla de plata tras perder
contra la japonesa akira zona y por
último una de las grandes sorpresas del
día la eliminación en la semifinal de
novak djokovic el número uno del mundo
quien fue vencido por alexander zverev
de alemania en tres sets 1-6 6-3 6-1